when we last left off we were looking at
two competing mechanisms for
substitution at sp3 carbon these sn1 and
sn2 reactions take place by different
mechanisms in the sn2 mechanism both of
these compounds this substrate with the
leaving group and the nucleophile are
involved in the rate determining step
the reaction coordinate diagram looks
something like this with this high
energy point representing a transition
state where we have partial bonds formed
and broken with the nucleophile and
leaving group
by contrast the sn1 mechanism goes
through a carbo cation intermediate thus
only this one compound is involved in
the rate determining step once the carbo
cation is formed it reacts with a
nucleophile to give products the
reaction coordinate diagram looks like
this with a low energy well for our
intermediate carbo cation in the sn2
mechanism we have inversion of
stereochemistry a change in
stereochemistry at a chiral center this
is because our nucleophile needs to
approach from the opposite face of the
leaving group and basically this
substrate flattens and kind of almost
flips like an umbrella turning inside
out in the high wind because the
nucleophile needs to approach from the
opposite face certain substrates like
this tertiary bromide cannot undergo the
sn2 reaction mechanism with these three
carbon atoms the nucleophile is
sterically hindered from approaching in
that way the sn1 mechanism goes through
a planar carbo cation the nucleophile
can approach from either face and we get
a mixture of stereo isomers as products
polar protic solvents increase the rate
of the sn1 reaction because they are
very good at stabilizing the formation
of ions which accelerates the rate
determining step by contrast these polar
protic solvents decrease the rate of sn2
react
Asians because they tie up the incoming
nucleophile and raise the activation
energy of the reaction however an sn2
reactions we do need polar solvents
they're just polar protic three examples
of which are shown here the structure of
the substrate is the most important
factor in determining if a reaction will
go sn1 or sn2 because the sn1 reaction
goes through this intermediate carbo
cation substrates that cannot form a
carbo cation will not proceed by this
mechanism substrates for which the sn2
backside attack is hindered such as this
tertiary substrate cannot proceed via
the sn2 mechanism and only has sn1
available to it I was depicting these
carbo cations in a geometry that mapped
on to this but please note that carbo
cations will always be trigonal planar
and look like this finally we met three
substrates that have both the sn1 and
sn2 mechanisms available to them so we
still need to explore a couple of
factors that will help us determine if
we have sn1 or sn2 in that case let's
dive into that now in the sn2 reaction
the nucleophile is involved in the rate
determining step this is pushing out the
leaving group here and so stronger
nucleophiles will promote sn2 reactions
in our borderline cases so how do we
know if we have a strong nucleophile
well there's all sorts of
nucleophilicity tables you can look them
up there's some that look at the
reaction of a nucleophile with methyl
bromide and measure the rate but for our
purposes we can say that nucleophilicity
roughly parallels basicity this is going
to allow us to use pk's to compare
nucleophile strengths this PKA
comparision works best when we're
looking at nucleophiles with the same
attacking atom
so let's look at two oxygen based
nucleophiles will compare acetate to a
thocks I'd well there's no proton to
remove here so we need to look at the
pka's of the conjugate acids this
conjugate acid acetic acid has a pKa of
4.6 and ethanol has a pKa of about 16
acetic acid is a stronger acid which
means it has a weaker conjugate base
acetate is resonance stabilized so it
doesn't mind losing this proton and
sitting around by itself quite as much
this makes a oxide are stronger
nucleophile the conjugate acid didn't
want to lose that proton in the first
place so this conjugate base is more
unstable it's more reactive it's a
better base and a better nucleophile
another trend is that nucleophilicity
increases as we move down a row on the
periodic table let's use ethanol again
and let's compare it to an analogous
compound using the element just below it
on the periodic table
this is ethane Thyle and it is our
better nucleophile in this case this is
a general trend larger elements tend to
be better nucleophiles this is because
their electrons are further away from
the nucleus they're smeared over a
larger surface area because this is a
larger element and so whereas these
electrons are going to be very close to
the oxygen atom
sulfur's electrons are a little bit
further away from the atom and so it's
easier for those electrons to distort as
they make that new bond and displace the
leaving group finally anions are going
to be stronger nucleophiles than neutral
species building on this example the
sodium salt of this compound is going to
be the stronger nucleophile we can draw
charges on these two atoms to see that
sulphur actually has a formal negative
charge with these electrons more
available nuclei
félicité increases now that we've
outlined are three general trends let's
just show you some examples of
nucleophiles that you might see in these
types of reactions so we met a thock
side up here hydroxide is also a good
nucleophile maybe in the form of sodium
or potassium hydroxide halogens are good
nucleophiles
for example chloride and iodide cyanide
is a good nucleophile this is a cool
example because it gives us a
carbon-carbon bond which is awesome for
building up carbon skeletons to make
more complex organic molecules azide is
a good nucleophile azide can be reacted
and then reduced to give an amine thiols
are also good nucleophiles as we saw
here these all have negative charge on
them so they have a lot of pushing power
these will be great nucleophiles for the
sn2 reaction when we're thinking about
our borderline cases now in the sn1
reaction the leaving group leaves on its
own the nucleophile doesn't need to be a
powerful nucleophile and we can actually
even have neutral nucleophiles had two
substrates in sn1 reactions so let's
write down a couple examples of neutral
nucleophiles we have water ammonia can
be a good nucleophile in sn1 reactions
and in the previous video we talked
about acetate or acetic acid being a
nucleophile in sn1 reactions so again
since we don't need the nucleophile to
push out this leaving group in the sn1
reaction neutral nucleophiles are
perfectly fine in fact in sn1 reactions
it's common to run the reaction with the
nucleophile as the solvent gives us lots
of molecules ready to attack that carbo
cation once it forms and these are all
polar protic let's look at one example
of a strong nucleophile promoting an sn2
reaction when this primary alkyl halide
is treated with sodium ethoxide we get
an sn2 reaction that produces an ether
this reaction is called the Williamson a
theraph occation
and works very well for primary halides
however with branched halides there's
something I need to tell you so if this
substrate was secondary or actually even
tertiary this is a strong base and
strong bases can actually promote a
different reaction that competes with
substitution called elimination instead
of substituting the sodium methoxide is
going to abstract a proton from the
substrate and this will form an alkene
elimination reactions compete with
substitution reactions if you thought
sn1 and sn2 was bad enough we have
another whole reaction pathway going on
but that's a topic for a different video
both of these reactions require a
leaving group to leave whether it leaves
on its own or leaves because it's pushed
off of the molecule so we need to make
sure that the group we have on here is
actually a good leaving group and of
course sn1 reactions are going to be a
little bit more sensitive to leaving
group ability but both of these
reactions do require a good leaving
group we'll find that the best leaving
groups are conjugate bases of strong
acids okay let's make sense of this
statement consider the ionization of HCL
in water this is a strong acid and
dissociates essentially completely what
this means is that the chloride ion is
really stable on its own it doesn't need
to hang out with its proton it
dissociates completely because it's
pretty happy just sitting around as this
anion well if it doesn't have a lot of
affinity for its proton it's just fine
leaving a molecule also in one of these
substitution reactions so this means we
can again use PK's to think about
leaving group ability let's look at a
few examples of good leaving groups here
we're looking at chloride bromide and
this o tousle toluene sulfonyl you can
look up that structure let's write down
their conjugate acids and now let's
consider the pka's HCL has a pKa of
negative eight HBR beats that with a pKa
of negative nine tousle alcohol has a
PKA
again negative a little bit less so at
minus one point three four and what this
is telling us is that these groups here
don't need to be associated with their
proton that much and so they're good
leaving groups okay now that we know
some good leaving groups let's look at
some poor leaving groups so we know
which groups we should not have on the
molecule if we want to do an sn1 or an
sn2 reaction we're going to look at the
leaving group its conjugate acid and the
pKa of that conjugate acid
the first one is hydroxide Oh H minus
rarely acts as a leaving group its
conjugate acid is water and that has a
pKa of fifteen point seven NH 2 minus is
also a poor leaving group the conjugate
acid is ammonia with a pKa of 38 we met
sodium ethoxide in fact all alkoxides
are going to be poor leaving groups the
conjugate acid is an alcohol and
alcohols have a range of PKA is hovering
around 16 now let's look at an example
of a poor leaving group that you might
not quite expect fluoride is one of the
halogens but it is a poor leaving group
in sn1 and sn2 reactions its conjugate
acid is HF and that has a pKa of 3.1
seven so you might not expect fluoride
to be such a poor leaving group based on
the pKa of HF however fluorine forms
very strong covalent bonds which makes
it unlikely to act as a leaving group in
sn1 and sn2 reactions before we leave
off I want to show one more reaction
example that will give us one more
awesome leaving group tertiary alcohols
can be treated with acid let's say hbr
and the electrons on oxygen can attack
this proton the alcohol is now
protonated because this is tertiary we
can't do backside attack due to steric
hindrance and this group leaves on its
own as a molecule of water this forms a
carbo cation that gets attacked by br-
this attack produces a tertiary bromide
so in this exam
we started with hydroxide which is a
poor leaving group it would never leave
on its own and we need this to undergo
an sn1 reaction since its tertiary but
protonating this results in an excellent
leaving group so let's add water as a
leaving group to our good leaving group
list the conjugate acid is the hydronium
ion with a pKa of negative 1.7 so we've
shown that our good leaving groups are
the conjugate bases of strong acids and
we could look at the pka's again here
we've identified a few leaving groups
that are very poor leaving groups now o
h minus is a poor leaving group but we
can protonate it to form water there are
other ways to make alcohols into good
leaving groups and i want to just finish
on those reactions alcohols can be
treated with a compound called Meisel
chloride or tousle chloride which forms
this leaving group in the presence of an
amine base to form these compounds which
are both good leaving groups alright so
we went over some methods to determine
nucleophiles strengths strong
nucleophiles will promote sn2 reactions
we looked at good leaving groups for
both sn1 and sn2 reactions and examined
some poor leaving groups and learned how
to convert alcohols into better leaving
groups as ever I hope you learned
something from this video if you did
please like and subscribe to my channel